[Music]
[Applause]
was walking right to say that modern
science has killed philosophy his
philosophy dead has it rendered
philosophy obsolete
should we now be looking to science to
answer the big questions and not
philosophy or religion or is there other
areas of science standing that science
can't reach each of our speakers will
get a few minutes to put their their
case will then have a discussion which
I'll gently direct and then we'll open
it up to questions from the floor so
without further ado Louis
a visible I think walking is absolutely
right he has my fullest support I've
never really understood what philosophy
has told us that wasn't obvious or
trivial
I must confess there are a couple of
exceptions
Aristotle really was quite useful very
useful when he thought about logic and
things like that
but otherwise I really understand what
philosophy is about what does philosophy
discovered perhaps they're going to
explain and tell us that there are
various things that science doesn't
explain science doesn't tell us how to
do politics but is there a philosophy of
politics now there's the study of
politics now the nice thing about
science is that you don't sorry
gives me make it clear there are people
who study the philosophy of science
that's true junk and I have a nice quote
very much and I have a nice quiet air
from a famous physicist Richard Fineman
philosophy of science is about as useful
to scientists as all mythology is to
birds he is absolutely right
there's no scientist that I know of any
distinction that takes philosophy of
science in any way seriously science is
really looking at evidence being
internally consistent and trying to find
out how things work and science has made
amazing discoveries and in doing
extremely well and it's got absolutely
nothing to do with philosophy I'm glad
to say because philosophy is sorry I
must tell you I do think there are a lot
of philosophers are very clever and the
language they're uses you know is quite
charming but empty empty beyond words
well thank you for being so delicate
Jonathan I dare say you have nothing to
I'm going to try and pull some meaning
into the empty vessel of philosophy
the short answer to the question has is
Hawking right to say that modern science
has killed for us of course since M is
known I'm going to say something in
direct response to what Louis just said
and then try and try and make the case
there's an important assumption that
shaped everything Lewis says that
philosophies junkless it doesn't
discover things and I think that's the
assumption that I want to question I'm
not I wouldn't deny that philosophy
doesn't make discoveries but that
doesn't render it I'm rendering OTAs and
I just want to start with a question of
clarification really it's not clear to
me what Hawking thought he was
pronouncing a death sentence on Hawking
says that the problem with philosophers
is they haven't kept up with recent
developments in science but I think the
problem with Hawking is that they hasn't
kept up with recent developments in
philosophy it's sick I suspect what he
had in mind was postmodern philosophy of
science or strong sociology of science
but it's worth saying that there's more
to philosophy than skepticism about the
ability of science to describe or
explain the nature of reality
oh the way the world is as it is in
itself independent of local perspectives
so there's more to philosophy I think
than Hawking and Hawking things only
make two broad points very very quickly
and again I think the first of these
points responds to something that
Lewis's just so the first point is that
philosophy or certain philosophical
assumptions patchy lewis well do play a
role in science and the second point
concerns the relationship between
philosophy and science and it seems to
me that there are better and worse ways
of defending philosophy against the kind
of attack that someone like Stephen
Hawking walking makes and the key to the
defense I'm going to try and sketch is a
distinction between Sciences and
explanatory enterprise and philosophy as
an exercise in clarification so let's
take the let's take the first of those
points s when Hawking is indifferent or
hostile to philosophy but it seems to me
that science brings with it a large
consignment of philosophical
and some of that Freight was evident in
what Lewis just said I'm talking about
assumptions about the nature of evidence
assumptions about the nature of valid
inference theory construction and so on
now those assumptions aren't always made
explicit in scientific practice but all
science practicing scientists
nevertheless take them for granted
second point and I'll be very quick the
second point there are better and worse
ways for philosophers and the defenders
of humanistic understanding more broadly
to defend what they do the bad way and
it's a way I don't think this is I don't
think this is how we should defend
philosophy the bad way is to insist that
philosophy and science are in the same
boat that's to say that and to say that
neither succeeds in describing the world
as it is as it is in itself independence
of local perspectives I mean we can't
denies Sciences extraordinary success in
delivering such things as planes which
stay in the air penicillin and less
benignly nuclear weapons so philosophers
should acknowledge that there are things
that science does better it's better at
explaining galaxies for instance but
there are also things that philosophy
does better for eggs for example making
sense in that burn of William sense of
human behavior making sense in
particular of our intellectual
activities the third corollary of that
point that science does something better
the corollary of that point is that it's
not to denigrate science to say that
there are certain domains of inquiring
pertaining principally to human behavior
that lie beyond the purview of science I
don't think to maintain that is to
denigrate the achievements of science in
any way just a simple example to
demonstrate and then I'll stop imagine a
cricket umpire he raises both hands in
the air to indicate that a six has been
schooled now we can describe and explain
that physical movement neurologically
and physiologically and that would be
very interesting especially if we do it
with the aid of MRI sounds and so on but
we can't understand that gesture in that
way to understand the gesture we need to
make reference to the rules of cricket
which are products of social life at
particular particular times so I would
say that there is something distinctive
about the way we understand
and clarify a human behavior that lies
beyond the purview of science and that
kind of understanding is historical and
it requires an imaginative
identification with the past thank you
Steve
first of all I want to say I will be
defending philosophy but on somewhat
different grounds from jonathan and i
should also say that i have some history
here with lewis is perhaps alluded to in
the beginning and i just want to say a
little bit about this because part of my
view about the relationship between
philosophy and science is that they're
not distinct disciplines strictly
speaking I think part of Jonathan's
assumption is that there's a division of
labor almost between the two fields and
I do believe that there's continuity
between science and philosophy and it's
quite legitimate for philosophers
especially at the normative level to ask
what is the point of doing science what
is the goal of science why should we
value this particular form of knowledge
over other forms of knowledge so that's
the level at which I would pitch my
defensive philosophy
visa V science is that in a sense
philosophy provides kind of a normative
focus for science and in a sense lewis
is presupposing certain philosophical
views about the nature of science that
gives his view such clarity and focus
and it's not something that as it were
is just given by the day-to-day
activities of empirical scientific
research i mean to give you a give you a
sense about this you know supposing we
took a scientific attitude toward the
history of science itself and we
actually looked at the empirical track
record of what science is produced over
the course of its history everything
it's produced everything that's been
responsible for everything that would
not have happened had it not been for
science and of course one can easily
talk about all the great medical
discoveries and all the the great sort
of technological innovations that have
enabled the world to be a more human
friendly place and so forth but also we
would have to talk about all the
devastation that's been done I mean
Jonathan alluded to the nuclear bombs
and things like this but also
environmental dis foliation over a long
period of time perhaps even a reckless
bringing into existence of human beings
for whom we had not thought in advance
we would be able to do anything with
okay all of that is also in Sciences
doorstep and if we did an empirical
balance sheet of the pros and cons of
science would we say that science is the
best form of knowledge and it was that
it was better to have pursued it rather
than not I don't think at a strictly
empirical level one would be able to
give that sort of answer
for modder bates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you